[Musique]
c'est euh
très bien de voir que vous savez qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de travail et de développement
dans tous les logiciels et c'est agréable
de le voir
fonctionner dans une situation réelle
[Musique]
et puis si nous pouvons le faire en restant en
sécurité en ce qui concerne les autres personnes sur l'
océan, les autres navires sur l'océan et également
faire face à tout ce que l'océan peut
nous lancer d'un point de vue météorologique,
les systèmes d'IA peuvent le faire, c'est un énorme
pas en avant dans la
réduction  le coût d'aller en mer pour
collecter les données dont nous avons besoin pour
mieux comprendre la planète et c'est
vraiment le but ultime
[Musique]
vous